we'll see whoa Knight C3 okay now now he
is now he is kind of lost yeah he'll go
on either 4 and 95 or F4 yeah but that
doesn't the issue is like this this
structure is a little bit too too solid
um and uh well okay so like a proper
motor Gambit here but unfortunately like
yeah this is uh uh I mean you're two
pieces down you're also the one getting
mated because the pawn H3 connected with
Queen G5 coming in at some point is
going to be very annoying yeah I mean
uh as a statement of intent it's fine
but yeah
not great from a boring purely chastical
sense let's put it like this
why is Magnus laughing because why
wouldn't you laugh
I mean they I'm pretty sure they like
each other and they understand the kind
of the the interplay here they both know
that
the game has gone off the rails very
very early on by sort of mutual
agreement and then
uh
uh it's kind of we used to play that
kind of really stupid game
uh when we were kids which I think once
again will demonstrate just sort of just
how screwed up of a childhood I had
and maybe it explains very many things
about me but we used to play this game
called nimsovich chess where basically
you couldn't make a move on the board
unless you could explain it using
sort of vaguely